winter is coming quite literally but  winter might also be coming  metaphorically for the european union if  we are incapable of action  in the next couple of days and weeks the  verdict was unequivocal meps were not  particularly forgiving to eu interior  ministers as they could not find a final  agreement after the meeting on september  14th in brussels what is happening there  is a shame the council meeting on monday  was a disgrace it didn't look like  i really urge you to vote for the  surgeon procedure claude morris and  martin schulz secured the vast majority  of their colleagues vote on an emergency  relocation scheme redistributing asylum  seekers across the european union on  september 9 meps had already approved  with an overwhelming majority a plan to  relocate 40 000 migrants from italy and  greece to other member states according  to frontex 500 000 migrants and refugees  found their way to europe between  january and august 2015